how about tesla coming out with their 25
cars so tesla just announced elon musk
says tesla will offer an affordable
drive
a driverless car within three years
for 25 000 announced during
battery k uh battery car meeting
520 mile range on the car the new
battery uses large cells with a
simplified design and lower cost
materials that can be manufactured
faster and 56 cheaper than the current
technology
what do you think about this elon musk's
new car uh 25 000
driverless car within three years is he
gonna deliver within three years no
i okay go ahead ladies first go ahead no
i don't you're just saying no he's not
doing it no i don't think it's to happen
i mean he's you know
i mean i i'm an elon fan i mean i think
a friend of the show
we talk to him all the time he's we talk
about him every episode i think the
guy's
brilliant but i mean you know if he
keeps smoking weed with joe rogan
he might not get this done on time i
think it'll that'll inspire him to get
it done
way sooner so he's kidding me so then
he's got to be back
and they got to smoke i think um
say it again pat they got to go back for
part two yeah i think so
i think look what's happening in
california these days what do we talk
about with governor newsom that he has
basically
he delivered an executive order banning
all new car sales uh that are gas
powered
by 2035. so in the next 15 years
no more new car sales in california will
have
will run on gasoline that's even more
wishful thinking okay
all right i'm not saying that's going to
happen or it's not going to happen but
that's the executive order that gavin
newsom uh
passed down so what does that you know
just go down there
as an executive order executive order
it's happening california kooky place
kooky place
uh we just came back from california
it's kooky place so what do you think
about it you're gonna
i think about it i mean look what are we
gonna do so who
what is the average cost of a tesla
right now 70 80 90 grand i don't think
it's
it's like 50 to 60k oh more than that
it's 50 to 60 is it
say 60k okay so all he has to do is make
more and make him cheaper right i mean
he's i mean he's working on a super car
right now that's going to go zero to 60
in less than
uh two seconds i mean less than two
seconds and it's gonna go 200
miles an hour but that's a completely
different story on what he's building
but who does this favor what governor
newsom is doing
it favors the the electronic karma i
actually agree with you
kai you were saying something uh no the
way i mean the way he's going at it
is he's just making cheaper batteries
he's going back to the to the
the natural materials and looking okay
this is what's expensive
this is why electric cars are more
expensive
and then they're trying to find new ways
to create new batteries that are cheaper
that takes down the price and i think
with innovation and especially now with
gavin newsom's order
and where you're having other companies
also kind of lining up
that that is the way it's going and if
we look at the innovation of computers
and how
it's grown over time i mean i think
there's no doubt that eventually we'll
get to that point with cars too there we
go that's kai ladies and gentlemen let's
not forget there's the competitor to
tesla that we don't hear that much about
this nikola which is tesla's first name
ironically yeah this nicola yep
and they partnered up with was it gm
okay
yes they partnered with gm and they're
going to be making their own
so i think the e the electronic car the
tesla's the nikolas
that's the wave of the future whether it
happens in the next three years five
years ten years
we're on that we're on that questions i
have so many questions i mean how long
do these batteries last
you know how do you dispose of them when
do they need to be replaced because we
went through a very similar situation
with plastics
and if you've watched the documentary on
plastics and plastics was the wave of
the future
it was supposed to you know say you know
save us and be reusable and all this
stuff and now we have tons and tons of
trash
that's not biodegradable you know i have
questions about this i want to know
about
you know the the impact to you know the
environment
in the future and i don't think that he
that's been addressed you know and i
want to also know like
how can a how can a government how can a
governor put down an executive order
like that i mean
it could potentially just be overturned
when the next governor's elected
touche we'll see we'll see what's going
to happen i mean i can tell you uh if
newsom came up with that by 2035
if there was a way for him to try to
save elon from leaving california that
may have not been a bad strategy by the
way if it was a way for him to get
elon musk to say okay you making this a
law i'll stay
over here but again tesla is a
international product i don't think he's
going to sit there and just the
the laws of california is going to say i
think that that this is something that
he could do
to uh sway elon to stay in
california i just don't see long's
personality as a guy that belongs in
california i see elon is a texas guy i
see alana's a florida guy silana's a
tennessee guy
i don't see lana as a independent as a
california guy yeah
he's very independent he's got his other
way in
you know california for a long time yes
he has been